olá boa tarde bom já começar o desporto
escolar olímpico com rafa vai ter que
ser o primeiro que está longe de mim é
preciso ter descaramento e depois porque
o cantor aquela situação do aço tiver
agressiva vocês devem ser simpáticos
mentira porque estes dias por acaso
melhor amigo apanhou uma cama com o
namorado miguel entrou no quarto e silva
até foi criado com uma solução na mesma
por isso a partida só um shopping no
galo favor passos mantém todos favor e
parece agora que comecem a pole problema
podem ser obrigado a fazer a minha mãe
que foi pole do país promover as
alterações do stand up não sei se
ninguém sabe o nome entre as atuações de
samba há sempre uma abordagem histórica
a paranaense
não temos esse problema porque ele é
juca vê só tenha luís vieira quinto a
calma e foi escolhida por isso ainda
aqui tem o hábito de mentir ainda que se
sou mentiroso saída que sumiram
mentiroso compulsivo com o antebraço por
favor ninguém ninguém quer assumir eu
posso falar das mulheres e homens para
cada mulher que são diferentes em tudo
que eu posso dar exemplos nós homens
somos desse tipo de golpe e um homem
vocês têm em busca de enfrentar a russa
nós homens temos chuva com isso a causa
é você tem axilas
enfrentar as axilas está o sistema
certamente diferente nos homens
o homem que é homem gosta do seu público
o desempenho é para ficar assim mais
bonita você não gosta do povo chinês
jamais vocês não gostam do coxa na
altura para gastar é de uma amiga minha
e do meu povo na mão ela lhe dá assim um
poeminha frente à escola não sabia que
ela talvez você está me irrita é uma
coisa por exemplo jesus só 14 que quer
tirar fotografias há 11 jogos terá uma
fotografia luis homem de estatura vida a
mulher não cometem todo um conceito ao
tirar uma fotografia com situava a
agitar o caminho ela ficará maquiagem
uma tropa em abril quase a fazer a ponte
só para tirar uma foto
nunca tanto você também tem uma coisa
que você nunca vai fazer que não seja
aqui existem casais mas aconselhou a
fazer isto que elas estão como vós
namorava a mostra na bolsa que vem já
minha mão estava segurando uma bolsa sem
parceiro homossexual
nenhum se não soltar e acionar a voz
luis rodríguez costa só marcas
importadas a minha carreira como
comediante tem aqui ao longe
eu estava na marginal sul do rio para a
semana com várias falas então foi uma
loucura pensar no parlamento e foi um
canal porque nela mas nas falhas do que
o preço foi foi um bocado chato
vamos passar algumas coisas na primeira
fase além disso a desculpa se lembrar
que estamos tão importante algo meu
limite para o humor
não porque apanha também faz o que
quiser
argumentos consistentes e extremamente
positivos a favor do modelo limite é
difícil fazer troça dos outros
nessa leva um limite de emoção cocó
esse é melhor não tem limite nas suas
anteriores mas precisam também ter meu
amor
vamos então passar para algumas coisas
que eu acho que nós fazemos que são
capazes tanto quanto vocês vêem como a
sua origem
o que você acha que vou fazer olham
certo a não violência
pra quem é que vai ser da minha mãe mas
eu quero ela se afastar e ali ele talvez
jovem daqui vai tomar a iniciativa no
entanto não são mariah contou como
começou a normal tomar a minha alma
chegou à ilha da paz 15
você fica aquela realmente aconteceu mas
quando era miúdo que ainda acontece um
carro ao longo da casa do amigo adriano
francisco não exportavam reforma pode
ser liberal nos oferecem comida oferecem
comida e nós vamos rejeitar sempre
então eu desmaiar mas a comida sempre
encontra um amigo meu programa mas
continuava lá que também na loja como
chico falando coisa normal mas também
acontecia na escola
isso é uma das grandes questões da
humanidade porque as últimas folhas do
caderno estavam sendo riscado de mil
sempre riscos dizem estou a passar
isso acontece mesmo tendo um caso quando
chegava com uma geração do facebook que
tal só que não cumprimento é que
consista tanto aquela pessoa que eu acho
que ela vai conhecer então não vejo na
rua e acontece mais ou menos isto que eu
vou andar
já estou aqui encaixar municipal
complementar ela não fica assim
eu conheço isso para o pai dois minutos
nunca vi então acreditar e 12
a gota de urina o animal estava chagas é
péssima
vocês pagaram 2 a 1 vamos unir à aliança
go domingo em que consiste o tempo os
homens então nós estamos originar nem
que os acura 15 meses oito cujo sai
sempre aquela gatinha nos acontece
será que sofrem campinense em casa basta
tem que ver essa merda
estamos acontece às vezes o pessoal
tanto a sua escrita com lápis
agora com o computador isso não existe
mas se você estava escrita com lápis
rico parte existe o avião existe mas
você não pegar na vila joão paulo ii por
outra vez lá no aves e vamos cair outra
vez nós vamos encarar a fila é que isso
acontece comigo acontece também convosco
como fazer uma previsão é que nós fixa
perigoso nunca se fica assim mais
nervoso e agitado ensaiaram clinton que
chegou haja qualquer um é gum deixou a
prisão nesta área está a obrigar com
certeza vai sair fiquei meio nervoso
é complicado quando está usando dar
incentivos aos erótico
tanto que motiva por causa da mesma
eu estou a andar e 5 todos com 19 tropas
não parece que eles aprendem a amar o
jogo ia andar do país
a escrita e gláucio tanto que nem a
europa nem tanto mas já tive uma fase
para fish na janela com os votos à
mostra mesmo todo e olhou e passa por
acaso o meu pai já existem alguns já
estão a ir no bom senso da mostra
ajeitar meu pai quando se achava me
socorro da concessionária foi o sepsi no
rio é fixo e aceitava 2011 e talento
isto estranho
acho que toda a gente os camarotes para
identificar
tem alguém na família que se dizem me
que esse contrato chegou então comecemos
por acaso no entanto é outro problema
que acomete mais as almas casa de banho
com sensor já vou fazer um cabo girão as
direções
já a equipe da casa longa casa branca
ninguém foi unânime
no caso a vaga em casa minha consciência
mas que é um sensor que não sei o que é
aquilo que eu tornar uma lenda ordinária
que o payroll então nós temos que amar
assim uma nova segurar e nós aqui temos
a lei fala dessa linha
acho que muita gente nem sabe como
falamos por alguém que não fala a nossa
língua vocês bateram as lojas chinesas
que vê nisto que alguém olha desculpe
quanto costa é isto não gastem a
tendência anual para o nível é nós aqui
é porque é uma chatice
eu tava falar mal das mulheres porque eu
já morei aí já começa com a namorada ea
menina mas sim mas a juíza aparece em
casa e não está ninguém eu pensei não
tava me admira
ok a immersion então tenho algumas
dificuldades em aceitar isso é preciso
carregar minério entre outras situações
por acaso ou tratava noite
ele entrou muita gente que ia lá e
quando chegava em casa com a tua
mensagem está tudo você acha que ela
deve ser sempre porque ela nunca mais me
ensinar
já namorei como sempre era visto tem
agora novas por acaso autora em junho e
também para nos lembrarmos ela estava
sempre mas sempre mas sempre a falar de
amor a ela falava tanto eu que tenho que
sentir a falta de capacitação
só espero que tenham gostado
basicamente como iria funcionar faça o
favor de ser felizes não só então a
sério porque ultimamente tem havido
algumas questões que estava no que toca
a gastar o limite do humor
eu tenho os meus limites mas encaro este
local como jogou no futebol sei lá 11 e
fez outro atacar tanto eu normalmente
veja mais a festa tem meu time temos
outros juristas por exemplo aposta no
modelo final countdown mães mais
polêmico
esqueçam isso não levem tão a sério esta
faça um faça o favor de ser felizes ryan
se mais homens mais perigosos e ouvimos
em cada disco entre olhos pra ele
desde o ataque mas começa a chorar mas
as outras outras questões que eu devo
ver nem citar mas basicamente é isso
sejam foi muito obrigado a sua luz via
ligar